Mary Mary quite contrary how do your
heretics burn
[Applause]
[Music]
Big Finish time once again and I was
actually quite excited for the one that
the patreon supporters I decided to have
him watch because yes if you join the
patreon you do get to help vote on what
Doctor Who related things we're gonna
talk about a month to month so hey get
the plug in there early and as smoothly
as you possibly can
nobody likes a rough insertion of a plug
I got a stop oh I'm sorry
anyways what they have selected for me
is a Sixth Doctor audio adventure which
I actually I'm really loving the Sixth
Doctor Big Finish stories and it's
really giving me an appreciation of what
Colin Baker's doctor should have been on
the show but wasn't and it really does
bring out the true pretend the true
potential of him in the role and the one
that I get to talk about this time is
the Marion conspiracy so this is the
introduction of what basically became I
think in arguably the most beloved
companion for The Sixth Doctor in the
audio era that is evylyn Smythe now this
is not my first encountering evilly
because she was in Jubilee which I
already reviewed last year but this is
her introductory story and I'm always
nervous at companion introduction
stories whether it is in audio or in or
on the show itself because they tend to
they tend to just not deliver on all
fronts more often than not which is kind
of par for the course because if you're
introducing a brand new companion you've
got to get all the logistics out of the
way of explaining for they are you need
to get them again figure out the dynamic
with the doctor we need to get to know
them and you're also trying to tell a
story in addition to doing all of that
things tend to get the short shrift I
think a big part of the way that this
manages to dodge that bullet because it
does is by doing something that doctor
who doesn't
do very often anymore and that is to
tell a straight historical and by that I
mean not only are we in a historical
setting dealing with famous figures from
history but there is no alien
there's no sci-fi wizardry there's
nobody is deliberately messing with time
it's just the figures who were around at
this period history and the doctor in
the companion encountering them straight
historical czar really a rarity at this
point I mean honestly that's not even
new that even the classic era kind of
got off them really kind of I think it
by the time the second doctor was done
they really didn't do them anymore
you still get things set in historical
settings but there would be an alien
there you know the master would be there
whatever but this is just dealing with
historical period and it fits very
nicely into Evelyn's backstory and her
characters so we have a slightly
simplified story because we're not
dealing with the sci-fi element inserted
into the history and the history that
we're doing doesn't feel like it's
taking away from us getting to know
evylyn because it feeds into what she
knows and what she likes and gives her a
lot to work with in terms of us getting
to know her as a character in same for
the doctor getting to know her so Evelyn
is a history professor professor and
sort of Elizabethan era England is her
specialty it's her focus it's what she
has a lot of interest in she has tracked
her own family back to those times and
that's kind of where the problems start
because something has happened that is
just like something's a little off and
time is trying to sort itself out but
things look like they might be slightly
off and the doctor has determined that
it is centered or at least tangent ly
related to Evelyn he's basically got a
he has whatever the six doctors
equivalent of the thing Tennant had and
the dead planet it dings when there's
stuff he basically has one of those and
he finds even with
like there's something going on and
you're at the Nexus of it and so he
travels with her back to Elizabeth Amy
she hardly misses a beat I love that
like he has a time machine oh all right
I'm just gonna go back in time and make
sure everything's going as it should
okay well then I'm going with you like
she is so wonderfully unfazed but not in
a way that's like you've seen it all
she's she's not unimpressed
she's just unfazed and I do think that's
a really fine line to ride because you
risk you know having the whole
disaffected no nothing moves me she's
clearly excited by all of this it's just
a lot of the stuff that characters
normally get hung up on she just kind of
like oh well I guess that's just how
that works then okay uh and she's just
very good at rolling with things and
she's also supremely unimpressed with
the doctor himself not in terms of what
he's capable of doing but just as a
person she doesn't think he's really
very much to write home about which is a
wonderful dynamic especially like God as
someone who came to know Doctor Who in
the modern Doctor Who era where the
Companions pretty much all of them even
you know the ones that I love they
worship at the altar of the doctor they
think the doctor is the end-all beyond
little and the most amazing thing ever
and it's refreshing to have a companion
who goes look I enjoyed traveling with
you but you're not everything you think
you are and I like that I love that
about her
so plot wise they go back and the
intention was they were gonna go back to
sort of the early years of Queen
Elizabeth the first reign unfortunately
they've showed up slightly early and her
sister Queen Mary is currently on the
throne and through some
misunderstandings about when they landed
they find themselves wrapped up with
some of the Protestant conspirators who
are either hiding from or in some way
attempting to dethrone or possibly even
kill Mary and there's a really there's a
lot of interesting
stuff sort of at play in terms of how to
deal with that because you marry is not
well regarded by history largely for
burning Protestants who wouldn't convert
to Catholicism and history is kind of
painted her as a monster which you know
that's a monstrous thing she did not
gonna say it's entirely unfair but what
I like about the story is it does still
treat her as a human being it never lets
her off the hook for what she's doing
but it also gives her the layers that
you can go oh yep this was a real person
this was not a caricature cackling
villain this was this was somebody who
honestly and sincerely thought she was
doing something good there's some
amazing conversations between her and
the doctor and then later between the
doctor and evil and talking about all
this where you know she she doesn't want
to be having people burnt at the stake
but she does believe that if she does
this and even if she does have to
actually burn people for it
that this is this will save somebody
that if she can scare basically through
these tactics just one Protestant into
converting to Catholicism and her mind
she has saved their soul and that is a
price worth paying if she can save even
only one soul and there's a lot of
kindness and love for her people at the
heart of what she's doing but what she's
doing is still monstrous because of the
way that she has latched on to this
belief and how to go about it and it's
it's kind of tragic in a way as the
doctor tries to get her to understand
what it is that she's doing but that and
and she even has some degree of
understanding and sympathy but still
ultimately falls back on but this is
still a heretical religion I can't let
this stand so it it's it's really well
balanced that entire dynamic and the
other and the other characters that play
are
are all pretty interesting there's
there's a priest there's a couple of
commoners there's uh there's a French
Bishop there's a there's a
lady-in-waiting to the Queen all sort of
you know involved and come up at various
points and everyone does a good job but
I thought I mean well the real highlight
here is is evil in but evil in the
doctor and Mary are sort of the the
trifecta of what the focus is and
they're all really good
I wouldn't put this at like the very top
of my list for the Big Finish I've
listened to because you know I tend to
appreciate the the slightly more
out-there stuff and some of the bolder
stuff you know it's a big part of what I
really loved about the Holy Terror it's
kind of what I liked about the fear
monger so and being a straight
historical it's not really gonna get out
there I mean it can't the nature of
telling you straight historical without
the sci-fi elements injected into it
means that's just not gonna happen but I
did still really like this it's really
well written it's really well performed
there's fantastic dynamics and some some
fairly well-made points and good
questions asked which again at the same
time it never feels like you know both
sigh be like you know there's merit to
both sides it's still very much going
like no what she did was wrong but still
sort of get trying to give some
understanding - you do have to
understand she is still a person who
believes she's doing right that doesn't
make what she did okay but we can't
pretend like she had no feeling about
what she was doing because she did
that's why she did it
so I thought it was I thought it was
well-balanced because it's it's
difficult um and obviously this is a
fictional story but whether we're
talking about fiction they're talking
about real history or things that kind
of bridge the two like this does it's
it's often difficult to try and humanize
monstrous people in a way that doesn't
feel like you're letting them off the
hook for the things that they did but I
feel like this was able to walk that
line really really well I was impressed
with this I need to I need to get some
more stuff with evylyn and and the six
doctor because they're really great
together
I like oh boy I mean we'll see what else
I got to listen to but they're they're
not that far off from like seventh
doctor an ace or ten or tenon and Donna
like in terms of like ideal pairings of
companion to doctor they're really
phenomenal so that's the Marion
conspiracy have you heard it what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments and we'll talk about it opens
just up to do buttons links the patreon
I mention they got a P o box it's my
birthday this month if you feel like you
know be generous send and stuff yeah
whatever I'm a selfish bugger what can I
say but anyway there's all that
information down in the description so
give it a look or don't that's actually
perfectly okay to gives at the end of
the day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]